[Música]
no es un secreto que israel y los países
árabes nunca se han llevado precisamente
bien de hecho siempre se han llevado
fatal tres guerras decenas de conflictos
diplomáticos acusaciones de todo tipo
vamos que el conflicto árabe-israelí ha
sido uno de los más calientes de la
segunda mitad del siglo 20 claro cuando
te llevas mal con tus vecinos tienes un
problema pero es que si además estos son
los mayores productores de petróleo
el problema se multiplica sobre todo si
tenemos en cuenta que israel ha sido
considerada siempre como un erial
energético los intentos por encontrar
petróleo nunca tuvieron éxito es verdad
que hasta 1979 israel tenía un buen
aliado la región sabéis cuál creo que os
va a sorprender
irán si así es el irán de los tiempos
del sha de persia era un estrecho aliado
de israel al fin y al cabo se puede
decir que han amigos con un enemigo en
común los países árabes a continuación
los emperadores de irán y los reyes de
españa se dirigieron en carroza
descubierta al sac jack abelhammer un
monumento erigido en memoria del
fundador del imperio persa ciro primero
la relación era tan estrecha incluso en
el 78 israel le ofreció ayuda al sha de
persia para construir centrales
nucleares pero todo cambió en 1979 con
la revolución de jomeiní a partir de la
cual israel e irán pasaron de ser
grandes amigos a grandes enemigos
[Música]
el caso es que israel ha tenido siempre
dos grandes debilidades primero una mala
relación con sus vecinos y segundo tener
problemas para garantizarse el
suministro de petróleo sobre todo ante
una situación de conflicto así lo
reconoció en 2004 el propio ministro de
energía de israel la situación de israel
es complicada no tenemos relaciones
diplomáticas con la mayoría de los
países de los cuales importamos petróleo
sin embargo amigos todo esto parece a
punto de cambiar
[Música]
el regalo de dios
así es como benjamin netanyahu el primer
ministro israelí definió los últimos
descubrimientos que israel ha hecho en
el mar mediterráneo descubrimientos que
pueden cambiar para siempre la realidad
geoestratégica de toda esta conflictiva
región de oriente medio
[Música]
claro puede que os estéis preguntando de
qué descubrimientos
estamos hablando muy atentos a este mapa
cada pieza amarilla representa un
yacimiento de gas natural descubierto
[Música]
y ojo porque no estamos hablando de
yacimientos precisamente pequeños el
último en descubrirse conocido como
leviatán es uno de los yacimientos más
grandes descubiertos en todo el mundo
durante la última década
[Música]
israel llevaba desde 1952 haciendo todo
lo posible por encontrar petróleo o gas
natural en su territorio para lograr la
independencia energética pero hasta el
año 2000 todos los intentos fueron
prácticamente en vano apenas se
encontraron algunos micro yacimientos de
petróleo en el desierto que la verdad no
valen de mucho si hace diez o quince
años hubiera dicho que israel
encontraría un depósito de energía tan
grande que le permitiría ser casi
independiente en materia energética
todos habrían pensado que estaba loco
éramos el país de la leche y la miel
pero cuando se trataba de petróleo se lo
dejábamos a nuestros vecinos sin embargo
gracias a la tecnología todo empezó a
cambiar en el año 2000 cuando una
empresa texana novelda energy descubrió
el primer yacimiento conocido como
maribel en alta mar este primero fue
pequeño pero con él dio comienzo la
carrera porque ya estaba claro debajo
del mar debajo del fondo marino había
sorpresas así que novel energy continuó
explorando el fondo hasta que en 2009
hubo premio
[Música]
y descubrió el yacimiento tamara que
éste ya sí tenía un tamaño respetable de
hecho este yacimiento le suministra hoy
a israel casi la mitad de sus
necesidades para producir electricidad
pero es que un año más tarde a israel
literalmente le tocó la lotería en 2010
tras gastarse 100 millones solo en la
exploración nobel energía y descubrió
leviatán un yacimiento gigantesco para
que os hagáis una idea se calcula que
este yacimiento y es más grande que
todas las reservas de gas natural que a
día de hoy han sido descubiertas en
países como bolivia o méxico
[Música]
aquí no acaba la historia porque casi
toda la zona está sin explorar de hecho
los estudios geológicos dicen que hay
debajo a 5000 metros de profundidad hay
muchísimo más gas natural y también
petróleo es más el gobierno estima que
el mediterráneo puede albergar en aguas
israelíes una riqueza descomunal de gas
natural y petróleo
[Música]
tal es así que el gobierno estima que en
total los yacimientos podrían albergar
más de 3 billones de metros cúbicos de
gas y 6 mil millones de barriles de
petróleo pero vale que son 3 billones de
metros cúbicos no es algo que fácilmente
podamos visualizar verdad pues para que
os hagáis una idea si se confirman estas
previsiones israel un país pequeñito de
apenas unos 8 millones de habitantes
podría entrar de la noche a la mañana en
el top 15 de países con más gas natural
en el top 20 de países con más petróleo
[Música]
y claro no todo es para ellos las
exportaciones ya han comenzado
precisamente a finales de 2016 las
empresas propietarias han llegado a un
acuerdo con el gobierno de jordania para
convertirse en su mayor suministrador
durante los próximos 15 años
el contrato supera los 10 mil millones
de dólares y ojo entre el 50 y el 60 por
ciento de todo este importe irá
directamente a las arcas del gobierno
israelí así es amigos de visual política
el gobierno de israel va a ingresar
decenas de miles de millones en las
próximas décadas y si se confirman sus
estimaciones podríamos estar hablando de
cientos de miles de millones pero aún
hay más porque en israel continental
petróleo convencional parece que no hay
pero podría haber ingentes cantidades de
petróleo de esquisto el que se extrae a
través del fracking
[Música]
de hecho los primeros yacimientos ya se
han encontrado vamos no es que israel
vaya a conseguir la independencia
energética algo que parece hoy ya claro
sino que además podría llegar a
convertirse en toda una potencia
energética ahora ya sabéis por tiene tan
ya jo considera estos descubrimientos
como un regalo de dios hace años la que
fue primer ministro de israel golda meír
hizo famosos de chiste déjenme decirles
algo que nosotros los israelíes tenemos
contra moisés nos llevó 40 años a través
del desierto para traernos al único
lugar de medio oriente que no tiene
petróleo pues parece que las tornas
están cambiando si a todo ello le
sumamos que israel es el país más
innovador del mundo puede que en los
próximos años llega a convertirse
también en uno de los más ricos por
cierto sabéis quiénes fueron los
primeros en interesarse por estos
yacimientos los rusos de qué país es
este coche que no hiciste y pero le
invito a que se dé una vuelta al y
satisfará hace unos años
quiso comprarlos al fin y al cabo todo
apunta a que en pocos años israel podría
arrebatarle al gas ruso una parte de su
cuota de mercado en europa y es que ya
lo sabéis nos lo contó fonseca con el
vídeo sobre arabia saudí y trump la
energía supone dinero y también
influencia
[Música]
aliado la situación internacional de
israel ha sido siempre cuando menos
controvertida guerras conflictos
políticos denuncias internacionales
resoluciones de naciones unidas vamos
que el ministerio de asuntos exteriores
de este país tiene más trabajo que papa
noel en plenas navidades
el caso es que aunque pueda resultar
chocante si tenemos en cuenta los
últimos acontecimientos en naciones
unidas el consejo de seguridad de la onu
aprueba resolución que condena los
asentamientos israelíes lo cierto es que
la política exterior de israel es más
fuerte que nunca si hasta ahora la
dependencia de eeuu ha sido casi total
eso es algo que las autoridades
israelíes se han empeñado en cambiar y
por supuesto los descubrimientos
energéticos han ayudado un montón por
ejemplo las relaciones con sus vecinos
están mejorando a pasos agigantados con
turquía las relaciones que se rompieron
casi por completo en 2010 cuando israel
abordó la 'flotilla de la libertad' se
están recomponiendo seguramente tiene
mucho que ver el hecho de que el país de
erdogán es un enorme consumidor de gas
natural y que sus acuerdos de
importación con rusia vencen en apenas
cinco años y ya sabemos cómo andan las
relaciones entre ambos países
turquía derriba un caza ruso en la
frontera con siria con sus otros vecinos
árabes egipto y jordania la cosa también
va viento en popa no sólo es que israel
se haya convertido ya en el mayor
proveedor de gas de jordania sino que
las relaciones con egipto están tan bien
que su ministro de exteriores- sameh
shoukry estuvo viendo la final de la
última eurocopa en la residencia del
primer ministro de israel y también
incluso lo impensable arabia saudí e
israel fortalecen lazos tras la máscara
de una ruptura diplomática otro país con
el que también ha estrechado mucho las
relaciones es con la grecia de cifras
que sorprendentemente se ha convertido
en un aliado muy cercano de hecho hoy la
fuerza aérea israelí se entrena en el
país heleno pero sobre todo el cambio
más importante es en el acercamiento a
oriente en vídeos anteriores os contamos
cómo obama apostó por el pacífico pues
podemos decir que israel ha hecho lo
mismo y en este proceso la india ha
jugado un papel clave este país ha
convertido a israel en su segundo mayor
proveedor de armas después de rusia y en
la última década la india le ha comprado
a israel más de 10 mil millones de
dólares en equipamiento militar las
relaciones son tan buenas que en 2015
por primera vez en la historia el
presidente de la india
hizo una visita oficial a israel y desde
entonces los encuentros se han repetido
con mucha frecuencia
[Música]
por cierto un apunte hasta ahora grecia
y la india habían sido países muy
críticos con israel como consecuencia de
la situación con palestina así que ya
podéis imaginaros que en el ministerio
de asuntos exteriores israelí esto se ve
como todo un logro y si también con
china israel está cuajando una relación
bastante estrecha con este país y de
hecho están negociando un acuerdo de
libre comercio además empresarios chinos
están realizando fuertes inversiones en
el país e incluso están construyendo un
puerto en la ciudad de ashton dentro de
su plan de la ruta de la seda
[Música]
y también vietnam corea del sur en fin
la apuesta de israel por asia está
siendo todo un éxito y si también está
donald trump que de momento se ha
comprometido ha hecho su friend of the
air water project of one hand held
percent en fin amigos aún queda mucho
camino por recorrer hasta que israel
pueda convertirse en una potencia
energética pero de lograrlo puede tener
un efecto muy positivo para la
estabilidad de la zona lo que sin duda
sería una muy buena noticia israel se
está convirtiendo en un gran país pero
aún quedan desde luego asuntos por
resolver por ejemplo el conflicto con
palestina que desde luego ha de
solucionarse
la fortuna es que unas mejores
relaciones con sus vecinos árabes
podrían ayudar mucho a este objetivo
bueno y tú qué piensas contribuir a toda
esta riqueza energética a la resolución
del conflicto lograr a israel aprovechar
esta oportunidad para convertirse en uno
de los países más ricos del mundo como
siempre esperamos vuestros comentarios y
si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no dudéis en darle al botón
de like i suscribiros al canal si aún no
lo habéis hecho y por supuesto no dejéis
de visitar nuestro nuevo canal en inglés
por cierto si quieres saber cómo logró
israel el milagro de convertirse en la
tierra de la innovación y las startups
no te pierdas este vídeo un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]